wrapper half ounce has died after being
shot on Monday night he was 32 years old
you know I have found something Beyond
open from Inglewood California I mean
I've been doing this [ __ ] since I
mentioned hey guys I've been in the
music industry I mean the same time I've
been around like number 11. I mean I
started reading I mean we're doing hard
I mean so 11 years old in a news release
shared Tuesday the Los Angeles Police
Department said they received quote
numerous Radio Calls of shots fired with
a man screaming on the 700 block of
South New Hampshire Avenue around 11 30
Monday night once they arrived at the
scene police say they found a man who
had been shot in front of an apartment
building according to LAPD at least a
dozen shots were fired paramedics with
the LA fire department declared the
victim dead at the scene people reports
the LA County coroner's office confirmed
the victim was indeed the musician what
inspired you to get into
I always that's what our reason I mean
went through that was my passion I mean
so yeah I mean but and then I started
messing with exhibits so yeah man so at
that time that's what he really like
introduced me to the industry police are
still searching for the suspect after
taking off in what they believe was a
dark colored SUV police also say that
half ounce was on the phone with his
wife who is pregnant with their fourth
child when the SUV pulled up and began
firing in addition to the baby on the
way half ounce was a father to two sons
a nine-month-old and a two-year-old as
well as an eight-year-old daughter
I just try to stay in the positive notes
keep positive thoughts y'all man just
stay away from negative people you
haven't tried to stay awake try to keep
my circle all positivity everybody in my
circle on the same note got me on
positivity half ounce is the latest
rapper to be shot dead in L.A pnb Rock
was fatally shot on September 12th at
Roscoe's Chicken and Waffles and rapper
key riches was shot and killed on
September 24th in Compton
[Music]
thank you
[Music]